[Música]
esto es ella soy de france 24 este 9 de
junio fue el aniversario número 28 de la
convención de belém para cuyo texto es
una herramienta para defender
reivindicar y exigir una vida libre de
violencia para las mujeres y las niñas
de américa latina y el caribe solo en
2020 la región registró más de 4000
feminicidios y el documento belem do
para aprobado en 1994 en brasil ofrece
los lineamientos para combatirlo y para
modelar legislaciones que protejan la
vida y también los derechos de todas
esto por medio de tres pilares que son
la prevención la sanción y la
erradicación de la violencia machista
una meta ambiciosa y que casi 30 años
después no se ha conseguido por eso en
el 2004 se creó el mes exit un mecanismo
de seguimiento de la convención de belém
de pará que monitorea e impulsa a los
estados para que adopten las medidas
y para conversar sin más demora la
conversaciones con no es silvia mesa
quien es experta del comité de expertas
del mecanismo para el seguimiento de la
convención de belem do para el mes sec
de gracias se sirve por estar con
nosotros en ellas hoy y qué puede hacer
la convención de belém do pará por las
latinoamericanas
buenos días primero muchas gracias por
la invitación
bueno debo decir que nosotros lo que
quisiéramos es que las mujeres las niñas
las adolescentes de américa latina'
conozcan la existencia de la convención
porque la convención que sepan que la
convención defiende su derecho a una
vida sin violencia y que las protege
porque conocer la convención es conocer
nuestros derechos melendo para es el
primer instrumento internacional de
derechos humanos
específicamente dedicado a la protección
de las mujeres frente a la violencia que
enfrentan a su derecho a una vida sin
violencia y esto es sumamente importante
porque la convención avn es más que un
texto la verdad la convención tiene me
sé que este mecanismo de seguimiento que
mencionaba donde los estados presentan
sus informes y se analizan y se les
hacen recomendaciones pero además la
convención
diseñado y puesto a disposición de los
estados leyes modelos una ley modelo
sobre femicidio feminicidio una ley
modelo sobre violencia contra las
mujeres en la vida política y también
tiene recomendaciones generales que
explican a los estados como se como es
la mejor forma de aplicar la convención
en determinada situación la tenemos
recomendaciones sobre
y legítima defensa en los casos de
violencia sobre mujeres y niñas
desaparecidas en la región y sobre
también el consentimiento en los casos
de violencia sexual y además tenemos
todo un sistema de herramientas que
harán que ayudan a los estados y les
exigen a la vez el cumplimiento de sus
obligaciones para
entonces podemos decir que la convención
tiene un impacto real verdad en la vida
de la mujer bueno pero son ya tres
décadas casi desde la adopción por
primera vez de este tratado que fue
pionero en su momento contra la
violencia machista con todas estas
características que usted nos menciona
que tienen ese tan anhelado enfoque de
género que necesitamos en américa latina
porque entonces sigue siendo un tratado
poco conocido y más aún diría usted que
poco aplicado por los gobiernos
latinoamericanos
si hemos ido avanzando en la aplicación
del tratado cuando recién se se hace
velando para cuando recién se se
promueve la red
peleando para a nivel de la oea una
primera reacción de los estados es hacer
leyes de violencia intrafamiliar que
protegían a todas las personas de la
familia sin darse cuenta que lo que él
ve lento para les exige es legislación
específica para la protección de las
mujeres
reconociendo que la violencia contra las
mujeres es un problema de las relaciones
históricamente desiguales entre hombres
y mujeres entonces ha sido un proceso
muy largo con los estados ha habido
mucha resistencia en los parlamentos de
la región el gobierno de la región
aplicar este tipo de medidas porque cada
vez que las mujeres ganamos derechos hay
algunos que piensan que los hombres los
pierden y en realidad no es así entonces
ha sido mucho en la resistencia hemos
avanzado ahora ya hay muchos países que
tienen leyes o leyes integrales de
violencia contra las mujeres la mayoría
de nuestros países finalizan el
femicidio pero eso no es suficiente
o sea para cambiar la situación de la
violencia como dice la misma convención
es necesario modificar los patrones
socioculturales que la que la están esté
reproduciendo
entonces eso es lo que garantizaría un
cambio real
en la vida de las mujeres de nuestros
países fue phil viajero en
discúlpeme es que es que quisiera
preguntarle porque es innegable esto que
usted no se está narrando y es que cada
vez más estados adoptan legislaciones
para combatir el feminicidio pero es que
ahora nos enfrentamos a otro problema y
es el paso judicial de estos casos para
que sean tratados como feminicidio
porque todavía hay muchísima resistencia
en los sistemas judiciales para asumir
que hay mujeres que son asesinadas todos
los días solamente por el hecho de ser
mujeres y por eso quería desviar un poco
el tema para que usted nos hable una vez
más de por qué es tan importante
tipificar el feminicidio en las
legislaciones y bueno ahí la importancia
de belém de pará
lo que no se nombra no existe decir
entonces si una legislación que
incluye el feminicidio o femicidio como
se llama en otros países dentro de su
ámbito legislativo dentro de sus códigos
penales o leyes especiales que los estén
tipificado como un delito está diciendo
varias cosas le está diciendo a la
sociedad que es inadmisible porque los
hechos que están tipificados como
delitos son cosas que son malas en
nuestro imaginario colectivo verdad
entonces eso es un primer paso de
prevención pero en segundo lugar es
necesario desde la prevención la
existencia de un proceso de capacitación
continuo del personal judicial del
personal policial para que los
femicidios sean reconocidos para qué
y no haya excusas para no aplicar la
legislación verdad porque hay muchos
sesgos de género hay muchos estereotipos
muchos prejuicios estamos trabajando en
eso en este momento en nuestras
sentencias muchas veces hay sentencias
que se resisten a reconocer que la
muerte de esa mujer fue por el hecho de
ser mujer hay sentencias que reconocen
que fue por eso pero resulta que ella
estaba engañando al señor entonces
estaba y fue un acto de
de una emoción violenta y así
sucesivamente mientras el personal
judicial no tenga el la sensibilización
necesaria mientras no comprendan que
tienen que ver estos delitos de
violencia contra la mujer desde una
perspectiva de género vamos a seguir
teniendo problemas en la aplicación de
la ley verdad en la violencia sexual
también nos pasa eso verdad que es
difícil es demostrar que una víctima de
una violación no consintió porque porque
se está exigiendo la prueba de que hubo
violencia o que ella se resistió
activamente y no todas las víctimas
pueden reaccionar así por eso
necesitamos una fuerte capacitación de
los jueces de las juezas de los
ministerios públicos y de todas las
instancias que intervienen en la
investigación de los delitos de
violencia contra las mujeres porque es
una investigación específica que debe
tener otros parámetros para que nosotros
consigamos una aplicación real de
nuestras leyes que nos están protegían
claro y en el caso de violación si me
permite pues voy a agregar para mí a
veces no es ni siquiera que sea difícil
de comprobar sino que existen la
voluntad de las autoridades para llegar
a esa prueba porque lo hemos dicho aquí
en muchos programas de ellas hoy la
reacción de muchas mujeres cuando son
víctimas de un abuso sexual es hacerse
las muertas y por eso es que no hay esa
prueba de resistencia que usted tanto
menciona bueno una de las misiones del
mc cvb y es hacer mediciones de
violencia en la región que me puede
contar de esas cifras que ustedes han
reunido tan juiciosamente en estos años
bueno tenemos algunos problemas con las
cifras verdad porque no todos los países
están teniendo las cifras al día la
mayoría de los países si tienen cifras
de atención pero resulta que las
situaciones de violencia no siempre
llegan a los estrados judiciales verdad
no siempre son denunciadas ante la
policía nosotros calculamos que menos de
un 20 por ciento son denunciadas
entonces la única manera de conocer la
situación de violencia de un país es
haciendo una encuesta nacional ahora la
encuestas encuestas son caras entonces
los países siempre tienen otras
prioridades y no priorizan
digamos periódicas de violencia con la
mujer algunos sí lo hacen verdad hay
países que tienen un intenso trabajo en
medición de la violencia contra las
mujeres hay otros que tienen un buen
trabajo con los femicidios pero no
siempre tenemos las cifras exactas lo
que sí tenemos es que se hacen rondas de
evaluación los países tienen que
entregar la información que les
solicitamos hay un sistema de
indicadores y se contesta dentro de ese
sistema
y después se analizan la respuesta de
los países y se le hacen recomendaciones
a cada uno de ellos las cifras como les
digo son difíciles de recopilar pero
sabemos por nuestra experiencia que la
violencia contra las mujeres no decrece
en nuestras hojas no decrece cada vez
aparecen nuevas formas de violencia
estamos trabajando también en por qué
hay tanta violencia y llegamos
a pensar bueno ya sé voy a pensar a
tratar de implementar cómo vamos a medir
la base de todas las violencias que es
la violencia sin política verdad que es
esa violencia imperceptible que no se
puede ver pero a través de la cual se
exige que las mujeres se adecuen siempre
a los roles que se les han prescrito
tradicionalmente y que cuando se salen
de ellos sean castigadas con violencia y
se justifica la violencia entonces si
queda mucho trabajo por hacer todavía y
estamos enfocadas en seguir haciéndolo
verdad o sea nos interesa
y garantizar la implementación de la de
la convención en todos los países
defender el derecho de las mujeres a
vivir sin sin libres de violencia y
alertar frente a las diferentes formas
que va subiendo asumiendo la violencia y
que las aportamos siempre aquí en ellas
hoy silvia un agradecimiento especial a
usted por toda esta aclaración y todas
las implicaciones que tiene la
importancia de legislar y en ese sentido
debe lm de tú para allá para el cierre
para nuestros televidentes que tengan en
cuenta que precisamente belem tú para lo
que busca es en esta convención acabar
con los estereotipos de la violencia
simbólica hacer hincapié en la
importancia de invertir en educación de
invertir en políticas públicas en acceso
a la justicia y en reparación de las
mujeres aún hoy todos los días suceden
episodios de maltrato y de violencia
machista gracias a usted sirve a
nuestros televidentes por estar con
nosotros nos vemos próximamente en ella
soy
[Música]